Esta reunión realmente ha tratado sobre una revolución digital,
pero quisiera argumentar que está terminada; hemos ganado.
Hemos tenido una revolución digital, pero no necesitamos seguir teniéndola.
Y me gustaría mirar más allá de esto,
mirar lo que viene después de la revolución digital.
Así que déjenme empezar a proyectar hacia el futuro.
Estos son algunos de los proyectos en los que estoy involucrado en el MIT (Massachusetts Institute of Technology)
viendo lo que viene después de las computadoras.
Lo primero, Internet Cero, aquí arriba -- esto es un servidor Web
que tiene el coste y la complejidad de una etiqueta RFID (Identificación por Radiofrecuencia)
alrededor de un dólar -- y que puede ir en cada bombilla y en cada pomo de una puerta,
y esto está siendo comercializado muy rápidamente.
Y lo que es interesante no es el coste;
es la forma en que codifica Internet.
Utiliza una especie de código Morse para Internet
así que puede enviarse ópticamente, puedes comunicarte acústicamente
al través de una línea eléctrica, o por radiofrecuencia.
Toma el principio original de Internet,
que es interconectar computadoras,
y ahora permite interconectar dispositivos.
Entonces, podemos tomar la idea entera que dio origen a Internet
y traerla al mundo físico en esta Internet Cero,
esta Internet de dispositivos.
Así que este es el siguiente paso desde allí hasta aquí,
y esto se está comercializando hoy.
Un paso adelante es el proyecto de computadoras fungibles.
Los bienes económicos fungibles pueden ser extensibles y comercializables.
Así, la mitad de la cantidad de grano es la mitad de útil
pero medio bebé o media computadora es mucho menos útil que
un bebé completo o una computadora completa,
y hemos estado tratando de hacer computadoras que trabajen de esa forma.
Así, lo que ven en el fondo es un prototipo.
Esto viene de la tesis de un estudiante, Bill Butow*, ahora en Intel,
quien se preguntaba por qué, en lugar de hacer chips más y más grandes,
no hacían chips pequeños, colocados en un medio viscoso,
y obtener capacidad de cómputo por kilos o centímetros cuadrados.
Y eso es lo que ven aquí.
A la izquierda ven postscript siendo procesado por una computadora convencional,
a la derecha ven postscript siendo procesado por el primer prototipo que hicimos,
pero no tiene memoria intermedia, ni procesador de entrada/salida,
nada de esas cosas - es sólo este material.
A diferencia de esta pantalla en la que los puntos están colocados cuidadosamente,
esto es materia prima.
Si agregan el doble de este material, obtienen el doble de pantalla.
Si le disparan una pistola en la mitad, nada sucede.
Si necesitas más recursos, sólo le aplicas más computadora.
Así, este es el paso siguiente - la computación como materia prima.
Aún son bits convencionales, el paso siguiente es -
este es un prototipo anterior en el laboratorio,
este es un video de alta velocidad proyectado a cámara lenta.
Ahora, integrando química y computación, dónde los bits son burbujas.
Esto nos muestra cómo se hacen bits, esto está mostrando --
de nuevo, a cámara lenta para que puedan verlo,
bits interactuando para hacer lógica, y multiplexación y de-multiplexación.
Entonces, ahora podremos calcular que el producto final organize la materia
al igual que información. Y, finalmente, estas son algunas diapositivas
de un proyecto que hice al principio, calculando dónde los bits son almacenados
al nivel de mecánica cuántica en los núcleos de los átomos, por lo que
los programas reorganizan la estrucutra nuclear de las moléculas.
Y todo esto está en el laboratorio avanzando más y más y más,
no como una metáfora, sino literalmente integrando bits y átomos,
y eso nos lleva al siguiente reconocimiento.
Todos sabemos que hemos tenido una revolución digital, pero ¿qué es eso?
Bueno, Shannon nos llevó, en los años cuarenta, desde aquí hasta aquí:
de un teléfono como medio para hablar que se degradaba con la distancia
a Internet. Y probó el primer teorema del umbral, que muestra
que si agregas información y se la quitas a una señal,
puedes calcular perfectamente con un dispositivo imperfecto.
Y fue entonces cuando llegamos a Internet.
Von Neumann, en los cincuenta, hizo la misma cosa por la computación;
mostró como puedes tener un computador poco fiable pero recuperar su estado
para hacerla perfecta. Esta fue el último gran computador analógico del MIT:
un analizador diferencial, y cuanto más lo ejecutabas,
peor era la respuesta que obtenías.
Despúes de Von Neumann, tuvimos la Pentium, donde el transistor mil millones
es tan fiable como el primero.
Pero toda nuestra fabricación está aquí abajo en la esquina inferior izquierda.
Una fábrica de aviones de última generación aplicando cera para metales a piezas fijas,
o tal vez derretir algún plástico. Una fábrica de chips de 10 mil millones de dólares
utiliza un proceso que el artesano de una aldea podría reconocer --
esparces el material y lo horneas.
Toda la inteligencia es externa al sistema;
los materiales no tienen información.
Ayer escuchaban sobre biología molecular,
que fundamentalmente calcula para construir.
Es un sistema de procesamiento de información.
Hemos tenido las revoluciones digitales en comunicación y cálculo,
pero precisamente la misma idea, precisamente la misma matemática
que Shannon y Von Neumann tuvieron, aún no ha salido
del mundo físico. Así que, inspirados por ello,
colegas en este programa -- El Centro para Bits y Átomos
en el MIT -- que es un grupo de personas quienes, como yo,
nunca entendieron la frontera entre ciencia física
y ciencia computacional. Iría aún más lejos y diría que
la ciencia computacional es una de las peores cosas que jamás le sucedió
tanto a los computadores como a la ciencia --
(Risas)
-- porque el canon - ciencia computacional -
muchos de ellos son muy buenos pero el canon de la ciencia de computadores
prematuramente fijó un modelo de computación
basado en la tecnología que estaba disponible en 1950,
y la naturaleza es un computador mucho más poderoso que eso.
Entonces, mañana escucharán de Saul Griffith. Él es uno de los
primeros estudiantes que terminaron este programa.
Empezamos a considerar cómo podrías "calcular para fabricar".
Esto es sólo la prueba de un principio que hizo con mosaicos
que interactúan magnéticamente, en los que escribes en código,
muy parecido al plegamiento de las proteínas, que especifica su estructura.
Así, no hay retroalimentación a una herramienta de metrología,
el material se codifica a sí mismo por su estructura de la misma forma en que
las proteínas son fabricadas. Así, puedes, por ejemplo, hacer eso.
Puedes hacer otras cosas. Esto es en 2D. Funciona en 3D.
El video en la esquina superior derecha - que no mostraré por falta de tiempo -
muestra auto-replicación, moldeado, para que algo pueda hacer algo
que pueda hacer algo, y estamos haciendo eso ahora en, tal vez,
nueve órdenes de magnitud. Estas ideas han sido utilizadas para mostrar
el ADN de mayor fidelidad y tasa directa para formar un organismo
en funcionalización de nanoclusters con enlaces peptídicos
que codifican su ensamblaje. Así, funcionan muy parecido a los imanes,
pero ahora en escalas nanométricas.
Micromecanizado por láser: esencialmente impresoras 3D que fabrican digitalmente
sistemas funcionales, hasta incluso construir edificios,
no por medio de planos,
sino haciendo que las partes se codifiquen a si mismas para a la estructura del edificio.
Así, estos son los primeros ejemplos en el laboratorio de tecnologías emergentes
para digitalizar la fabricación. Computadoras que no controlan herramientas
sino computadoras que son herramientas, en donde la salida de un programa
reordena los átomos así como los bits.
Ahora, para hacer eso - con sus impuestos, muchas gracias -
compré todas estas máquinas. Hemos hecho una modesta propuesta
a la Fundación Nacional para las Ciencias (NSF). Queríamos ser capaces de hacer cualquier cosa en cualquier escala,
todo en un lugar, porque no puedes separar la fabricación digital
por disciplinas o por una escala de longitud.
Así que juntamos nano-rayos escritores enfocados
y cortadores supersónicos de agua y sistemas de micro-mecanización de excímeros
Pero tenía un problema. Una vez que tuve todas estas máquinas,
perdía mucho tiempo en enseñar a los estudiantes cómo usarlas.
Así que empecé una clase, modestamente llamada,
"Cómo hacer prácticamente todo". Y no pretendía ser provocativo,
era solo para unos cuantos estudiantes de investigación.
Pero el primer día de clase se veía así.
Ya saben, cientos de personas llegaron rogando,
"toda mi vida esperé por esta clase, haré todo lo necesario para lograrlo".
Entonces preguntaban, ¿puede enseñarlo en el MIT? ¿Parece muy útil?
Y entonces la siguiente --
(risas)
-- cosa sorprendente era que no estaban allí para hacer investigación.
Ellos querían la clase porque querían hacer cosas.
No tenían formación técnica convencional.
Y al final del semestre habían integrado sus capacidades.
Les voy a mostrar un viejo video. Kelly era una escultora, y esto es lo que hizo
con su proyecto semestral.
(Video): Kelly: Hola, soy Kelly y este es mi amigo gritón.
¿Te has encontrado alguna vez en una situación
en la que realmente necesitas gritar, pero no puedes porque estás en el trabajo,
o en un salón de clase, o estás cuidando a tus niños,
o te encuentras en una de esas situaciones en las que simplemente no está permitido?
Bueno, el amigo gritón es un espacio portátil para gritar.
Cuando un usuario grita en su amigo gritón, su grito es silenciado.
También se graba para liberarlo posteriormente, donde, cuando y como
el usuario elija.
(Grito)
(Risas)(Aplausos)
Bien, a Einstein le gustaría esto.
Este estudiante hizo un navegador Web para loros --
que le permite a los loros navegar la red y hablar con otros loros.
Este estudiante hizo un reloj despertador con el que luchas
para demostrar que estás despierto. Este es uno que defiende --
un traje que defiende tu espacio personal.
Esto no es tecnología para la comunicación;
es tecnología para prevenirla.
Este es un dispositivo que te permite ver tu música.
Este es un estudiante que hizo una máquina que hace máquinas,
y la construyó haciendo Lego Bricks® que hacen los cálculos.
Esto es año tras año -- y finalmente me di cuenta
que los estudiantes estaban mostrando que la aplicación definitiva de la fabricación personal
es productos para un mercado de una persona.
No necesitas esto para lo que puedes encontrar en tiendas Wal-Mart;
necesitas esto para lo que te hace único.
Ken Olsen (CEO de DEC en 1977) célebremente dijo, "nadie necesita una computadora en su casa".
Pero no se usa para inventarios o nóminas
DEC está ahora doblemente en bancarrota. No necesitas fabricación personal
en la casa para comprar lo que puedes comprar porque puedes comprarlo.
Lo necesitas para lo que te hace único, como la personalización.
Entonces, con esto, a su vez, 20 millones de dólares hoy hacen esto,
dentro de 20 años vamos a hacer replicadores de Star Trek que hacen cualquier cosa.
Los estudiantes "secuestraron" todas las máquinas que compré para hacer fabricación personal.
Hoy en día, cuando gasta tanto de su dinero,
hay un requisito del gobierno para hacer divulgación, que normalmente significa
clases en la escuela local, un sitio web, cosas que no son tan emocionantes.
Por lo tanto, hice un trato con mi directores de programa de la NSF
que en lugar de hablar de ello, le daría a la gente las herramientas.
Esto no estaba destinado a ser provocativo o importante,
pero creamos estos Fab Labs (Laboratorios Fabulosos). Son aproximadamente 20.000 dólares en equipo
que se aproximan tanto a lo que los 20 millones de dólares hacen como a donde se dirigen.
Un cortador láser para hacer montaje "press-fit" (ajustado a presión) con 3D a partir de 2D,
un plotter de corte para trazar en cobre para hacer electromagnetismo,
un micrómetro,
una fresadora controlada numéricamente para estructuras precisas,
herramientas de programación por menos de un dólar,
microcontroladores de 100 nanosegundos, te permiten trabajar desde micro
y milisegundos en adelante, y explotaron en todo el mundo.
No estaba planificado, pero fueron de los suburbios de Boston
a Pobal en la India, a Secondi-Takoradi en la costa de Ghana
a Soshanguve en un poblado en Sudáfrica,
al extremo norte de Noruega, descubriendo, o ayudando a descubrir,
por toda la atención a la brecha digital,
nos encontraríamos con computadoras sin uso en todos estos lugares.
Un granjero en un pueblo rural - un niño necesita medir y modificar
el mundo, no sólo obtener información sobre él en una pantalla.
Que hay realmente una brecha de fabricación e instrumentación
más grande que la brecha digital
Y la manera de cerrarla no es TI (Tecnologías de la Información) para las masas, sino de desarrollo de TI para las masas.
De esta forma, lugar tras lugar
vimos la misma progresión: que habíamos abierto uno de estos Fab Labs,
donde -- nosotros no -- esto es muy loco para pensar en ello.
Nosotros no planeamos todo esto, que seríamos llevados a estos lugares,
donde lo habíamos abierto. El primer paso fue solamente darle el poder a la gente.
Puedes verlo en sus caras, simplemente esa alegría de "puedo hacerlo".
Esta es una niña de los suburbios de Boston que acababa de hace una venta de
artesanías de alta tecnología bajo demanda en el centro comunitario de la ciudad.
Va de allí a la educación técnica práctica seria,
informalmente, fuera de las escuelas. En Ghana hemos levantado uno de estos laboratorios
Diseñamos un sensor de redes, y los niños aparecían
y rehusaban irse del laboratorio.
Había una niña que insistió en que nos quedásemos hasta tarde por la noche --
(Video): Niños: Me encanta el Fab Lab.
-- en su primera noche en el laboratorio porque iba a construir el sensor.
Así que insistió en fabricar el circuito impreso, aprendiendo como armarlo,
aprendendiendo como programarlo. Ella no sabía realmente
lo que estaba haciendo o por qué lo hacía, pero sabía
que tenía que hacerlo. Había algo de eléctrico en ello.
Esto es tarde, ¿saben?, a las 11 en punto de la noche
y creo que yo era la única persona sorprendida cuando lo que construyó
funcionó la primera vez.
Y he mostrado esto a ingenieros en grandes compañías, y ellos dicen
que no pueden hacerlo. Cualquier cosa que ella esté haciendo, ellos pueden hacerla mejor,
pero está distribuido entre mucha gente y muchos sitios
y no pueden hacer en una tarde
lo que está haciendo esta niña de una zona rural de Ghana.
(Video): Niña: Mi nombre es Valentina Kofi, tengo ocho años de edad.
Hice un circuito apilado.
Y, de nuevo, era sólo por el placer de hacerlo.
Entonces estos laboratorios comenzaron a resolver problemas más serios --
instrumentación para la agricultura en la India,
turbinas de vapor para la conversión de energía en Ghana,
antenas de alta ganancia en computadores clientes ligeros.
Y luego, a su vez, los negocios comenzaron a crecer,
como la fabricación de estas antenas.
Y, por último, el laboratorio comenzó a hacer invenciones.
Estamos aprendiendo más de ellos de lo que les estamos dando.
Estaba mostrando a mis hijos en un Fab Lab cómo usarlo.
Inventaron una manera de hacer un kit de construcción a partir de una caja de cartón --
que, como ven ahí arriba, se está convirtiendo en un negocio --
pero su diseño era mejor que el diseño de Saúl en el MIT,
así que ahora hay tres estudiantes en el MIT basando sus tesis en
ampliar el trabajo de niños de ocho años de edad
porque tenían mejores diseños.
La invención real está ocurriendo en estos laboratorios.
Y aún mantenía -- de esta forma, en el último año he estado pasando tiempo con
jefes de estado y generales y jefes tribales, todos los cuales lo quieren,
y sigo diciendo, pero esto no es lo real.
Esperen unos 20 años y entonces habremos terminado.
Y finalmente entendí lo que está pasando. Estos son Kernigan y Ritchie
inventando UNIX en un PDP (Procesador de Datos Programado).
Los PDP aparecieron entre los mainframes y las minicomputadoras.
Costaban decenas de miles de dólares, difíciles de usar,
pero llevaron la informática a los grupos de trabajo,
y todo lo que hacemos hoy en día sucedió allí.
Estos Fab Labs tienen el coste y la complejidad del PDP.
La proyección de fabricación digital
no es una proyección para el futuro; ahora estamos en la era del PDP.
En ese entonces, hablábamos en voz baja acerca de los grandes descubrimientos.
Fue muy caótico, no era, de alguna forma, claro lo que estaba pasando.
En el mismo sentido estamos ahora, hoy, en la era del minicomputador
de la fabricación digital.
El único problema con eso es que rompe las fronteras de todo el mundo.
En Washington DC, voy a cada agencia que quiera hablar, uds. saben.
En el Área de la Bahía (San Francisco), voy a todas las organizaciones que se puedan imaginar.
Todos quieren hablar de ello, pero rompe
los límites de su organización. De hecho, es ilegal para ellos,
en muchos casos, equipar a la gente común para crear
en lugar de consumir tecnología.
Y el problema es tan grave que la última invención
procedente de esta comunidad me sorprendió:
es la ingeniería social. Que el laboratorio en el extremo norte de Noruega --
esto está tan al norte que sus antenas parabólicas miran al suelo
en vez de al cielo porque ahí es donde están los satélites --
al laboratorio se le quedó chico el pequeño granero en el que estaba.
Estaba allí porque querían encontrar animales en las montañas
pero creció demasiado, así que construyeron este pueblo extraordinario para el laboratorio.
Esto no es una universidad, no es una empresa, es esencialmente
un pueblo para la invención, es un pueblo para miembros atípicos de la sociedad,
y han estado creciendo en torno a estos Fab Labs
en todo el mundo.
Así que este programa se ha dividido en una ONG,
una Fundación Fab para apoyar la ampliación, un micro fondo de capital riesgo.
La persona que lo lleva a cabo lo describe muy bien como
máquinas que fabrican máquinas necesitan negocios que hagan negocios:
es un cruce entre micro créditos y fondo de capital riesgo para hacer fan-out,
y luego los grupos de investigación allí en el MIT que
lo están haciendo posible.
Así que me gustaría dejarles con dos pensamientos.
Ha habido un enorme cambio en la ayuda, de mega-proyectos muy jerarquizados
a inversión de micro créditos en las bases por parte de grupos gente común poco estructurados
así que todos entendieron que eso es lo que funciona.
Pero todavía vemos a la tecnología como mega-proyectos muy jerarquizados.
Informática, comunicaciones, energía para el resto del planeta
son estos mega-proyectos jerarquizados.
Si esta sala llena de héroes es lo suficientemente inteligente,
pueden resolver los problemas.
El mensaje que llega desde los Fab Labs es que
los otros cinco mil millones de personas en el planeta
no son sumideros técnicos; ellos son fuentes.
La oportunidad real es aprovechar el poder de inventiva del mundo
para diseñar y producir localmente soluciones a los problemas locales.
Yo creía que esa era una proyección de aquí a 20 años,
pero es donde estamos hoy.
Rompe todas las barreras organizacionales que podamos imaginar.
Lo más difícil en este punto es la ingeniería social
y la ingeniería organizacional, pero ya está presente hoy.
Y, por último, cualquier charla de este tipo sobre el futuro de la computación
requiere mostrar la ley de Moore, pero mi versión favorita --
esta es la original de Gordon Moore, de su trabajo original --
y lo que ha sucedido es que, año tras año tras año,
hemos calculado y calculado y calculado
y calculado y calculado y calculado
y calculado y calculado
y está la amenaza de este error que sucederá
al final de la ley de Moore; este error fatal se acerca.
Pero lo que estamos llegando a apreciar, es que la transición de 2D a 3D
de programar bits a programar átomos,
cambia el final de la gráfica de la ley de Moore del error fatal
a una función última.
Entonces, estamos justo al borde de esta revolución digital en la fabricación,
donde los resultados de la computación programen el mundo físico.
Así que, en conjunto, estos dos proyectos responden preguntas
que no había formulado con cuidado. La clase en el MIT muestra que la aplicación definitiva
para la fabricación personal en el mundo desarrollado
es la tecnología para un mercado de uno: la expresión personal en la tecnología
que toca una pasión como nada que yo haya visto en la tecnología
desde hace mucho tiempo.
Y la aplicación definitiva para el resto del planeta es la instrumentación
y la brecha de la fabricación: gente desarrollando localmente soluciones
a problemas locales. Gracias.